I think when we did the work and this
was work that was done I was between the
ages of 20 and 25 so I was very young I
think we thought the work was exciting
but I think a scientist always thinks
they work as a sighting and there's a
big difference from even if you think
your work is exciting and having an
impact to get a Nobel Prize it's got to
be a certain area and I think I've
always worked in many different areas so
I i think was quite hard for them to
find one area that went right back to
the beginning so I was certainly
surprised you know I think that in
science you hardly ever have a Eureka
moment you have lots of little Eureka
moments like I've just found an error in
a program or will that leave my keys or
whatever but I think that it's much more
so science it's sort of a mixture of
ideas and lots of hard work and you know
and being very persistent I think you
have to not give up you have to believe
in yourself we have to realize that if
it's a new idea people are not going to
like it if people like it then it's not
a good idea